I mean which is just wild I mean it's
just so blatant and so in yourr face
yeah it's weird so I want to flash
forward now to five and a half years
after that clip on Joe Rogan to Joe
Rogan's show last week so now he had
Elon on and here's Elon basically saying
that Twitter 1.0 run by those two people
we just showed you right there was a
government organization what was that
like is that to me that was the most
bizarre was the Twitter files when you
let shellenberger and Matt taibe those
guys get in the Twitter and the response
where Matt taiii gets audited I mean
which is just wild I mean it's just so
blatant and so in your face yeah it's
weird no I
mean the yeah the the to which and and
by the way Jack didn't really know know
this but the degree to which Twitter was
simply um an arm of the government was
not well understood by the public and uh
it was there was no it was whatever the
official govern I it was like prda
basically um you know it's a state
publication is the way to think of old
Twitter it's a state publication and was
the justification from their perspective
that they are progressive liberals they
have the right intentions it's important
that they stay in power the progressive
liberals stay in government and power
because this is the this is their there
there was there was uh basically
oppression of
um any any views that would even I would
say be considered middle of the road um
but certainly anything on the the right
I'm not talking about like like far
right I'm just talking mildly right the
people like Republicans were suppressed
at 10 times the rate of Democrats um now
that's because uh old Twitter was
fundamentally controlled by the
farle it was like completely controlled
by the the farle so harid I think most
people watching that they get it they
now see that uh Elon has done good with
Twitter I think there's still a huge
amount of problems there and you just
mentioned the sock puppet accounts I
mean I'm seeing more Bots and sock
puppets it's like it's absolutely insane
there but he's clearly trying yeah all
of that being said do you have hope that
say Facebook and Google and YouTube
YouTube's the number two search engine I
think Twitter is now sorry I think Tik
Tok is now the number one search engine
do you have any hope that any of these
things could be reformed through the
government or or their on their own well
so not on their own and not through the
government and God forbid that our
freedom of speech hinges on the whims of
one billionaire much as we love him he's
done with with Twitter but uh that
cannot be the situation and for years
like I said I've been pleading with
members of Congress who I have access to
do something about this you just need to
pass a law we could have done it at the
beginning of the Trump Administration
they didn't do it and it needs to be
done and this is a bipartisan issue I do
not want or I don't want Republican
presidents and Republican governments
censoring the left either people have a
right to free speech in our country and
if you by the way if uh if Twitter is
Prova imagine what the New York Times
And The Washington Post and the San
Francisco Chronicle and all these other
Rags what are they that so it's a it's a
poorly kept secret that what we see has
been heavily manipulated by our
government for many years and citizens
should have a right and a private right
of action believe me if lawyers start
filing lawsuits and real money exchanges
hands this will stop